What did the Christian settlers find when
they came to the New World?
They found a lot of civilizations that
were murdering babies in
weird religious rituals.
I fact-checked VP Vance's claims about
colonialism with original sources.
Here's what historians actually say.
Alright, so he's saying Christian
settlers found
civilizations murdering babies.
Let's look at who English settlers
actually encountered.
They met the Powhatan, Wampanoag,
Iroquois and Algonquin peoples.
Archaeological surveys of these societies
shows that there's zero
evidence of child sacrifice.
These were
decentralized kinship-based groups.
They didn't have the state structures
that practiced
large-scale ritual sacrifice.
There is one exception, the Pawnee
Morningstar ceremony in Nebraska,
2,000 miles from where
the English settlers landed.
So, no, English settlers didn't find
widespread child sacrifice.
Now, Spanish conquistadors in Central
Mexico and South America,
that's a different story.
Child sacrifice did occur in
Aztec, Maya and Inca societies.
Recent archaeological work confirms this.
There's a 2024 DNA
study in Nature about it.
But here's where it gets interesting.
Mexican archaeologists found 126
individuals at the Templo Mayor site,
across all types of sacrifice.
Spanish chronicler Diego Durán claimed
over 80,000 victims in a single 1487
ceremony at that complex.
The Codex de Lariano Remensis, written
by elderly Aztec informants,
reports about 4,000
victims for that ceremony.
That's 20 times inflation.
Still horrific, but the Spanish accounts
were still
exaggerating four to eight times.
Historian Matthew Restel
documents this pattern.
Spanish conquistadors consistently
inflated accounts of indigenous practices
to justify what they were about to do.
Which brings us to a question.
Why does anyone in 2025 care about
rehabilitating these myths?
Why spend six minutes
fact-checking 500-year-old myths?
Because Vance isn't
just talking about history.
In January 2025, he used what he calls
"ordo amores", a hierarchical ordering of
love, to justify cutting foreign aid.
His explanation?
You love your family first, then your
neighbor, then your community.
This is the same hierarchical logic.
We are superior, they are far away,
therefore we decide what they deserve.
When politicians rehabilitate colonial
propaganda, they're not
teaching bad history for fun.
They're building a worldview where
exploitation is justified.
And in fact, it was a Christian empire,
Great Britain, that
abolished slavery to begin with.
Actually, the first nation in the Western
Hemisphere to permanently
abolish slavery was Haiti, in 1804.
And here's what makes this relevant.
They did it by defeating the French,
British and Spanish armies who were
trying to keep them enslaved.
The Haitian revolution was enslaved
people fighting against Christian empires
that wanted to maintain slavery.
They won.
And 29 years before
Britain's 1833 abolition.
Now about that Christian empire claim.
Richard Furman, president of the South
Carolina Baptist Convention in 1822.
The right of holding slaves is clearly
established in the Holy Scriptures.
Jefferson Davis,
president of the Confederacy.
Slavery was established
by decree of Almighty God.
Pope Nicholas V in 1452, authorized the
Portuguese to enslave Saracens, pagans
and other enemies of Christ.
The Methodist Church
split in 1844 over slavery.
The Southern Baptist Convention was
founded in 1845
specifically to defend it.
Christians didn't just abolish slavery.
Christians also defended slavery for
centuries using the Bible.
If you go to historical archaeological
sites where there were brothels,
the oldest businesses in the world are
gambling and prostitution, and there were
brothels, even in very ancient
civilizations.
If you go back to ancient brothels and
you dig up the bones of the women who are
working in these places,
you will very often find a lot of
children who were buried with them.
Okay, this one's interesting because he's
repeating archaeology from the 1980s and
90s that has been debunked.
Multiple sites in Roman
Britain got this treatment.
Infant burials were found.
The media runs with brothel infanticide
and it becomes common knowledge.
Yewden Villa in England, Ashkelon in
Israel, several others.
Then DNA testing happens in the 2010s and
the interpretation falls apart.
2014 DNA analysis of Yewden Villa.
Balanced male to female ratio.
All from different mothers.
No trauma, proper burial, 97 infant
deaths over 300 years of occupation.
That's 0.32 per year.
Normal infant mortality for the period.
2015 Cambridge University.
We trust that this evidence disposes once
and for all with the suggestion that
infanticide was the
norm in Roman Britain.
Bioarchaeologist Sian Halcrow in 2017
specifically called this out.
Whole cemeteries of
unwanted brothel babies.
These are sensational research stories
that capture headlines but misrepresent
archaeological evidence.
Vance is repeating headlines that modern
science has rejected.
And even if they were true, which they
are not, all these sites are from Roman
Europe, not the Americas.
Three claims checked, none held up.
Part 2 drops on Thursday.
I'm fact checking his claims about human
rights, religious freedom and whether
Christian civilization is
the most moral in history.
Subscribe so you don't miss it.